[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi siete mai chiesti che ruolo ha avuto
il piano b nella vostra carriera
professionale o universitaria
oggi vorrei raccontarvi la mia
esperienza
era il 31 agosto
1998 ed era il mio primo giorno di
lavoro
appena diplomata in ragioneria
avevo subito trovato un posto fisso in
impregilo in amministrazione contabilità
ero molto emozionata quel giorno tra
l'altro per qualche motivo ero finita
nell'ufficio con la responsabile
amministrativa di tutto il gruppo
sono le due del pomeriggio quando la mia
responsabile mi dice è il momento di
fare il giro di presentazione dei
diversi uffici
andiamo a un certo punto arriviamo
davanti a una porta con una targhetta
contabilità fornitori
entriamo e lì sulla destra c'era il
signor luciano
signor luciano era un uomo di mezza età
magro con la carnagione scura una
montatura adorata anni 70 dietro di lui
un armadio di metallo enorme dove si
intravedevano i faldoni all'interno dei
quali aveva accuratamente
catalogato le fatture fornitori e lui
era lì seduto alla sua scrivania
e a me sembrava fosse il guardiano di un
tesoro
ad un certo punto signor luciano mi dice
una semplicissima frase io sono 41 anni
che lavoro in contabilità fornitori
ma me lo disse in un modo che non solo
lasciava trasparire il suo profondo
senso di soddisfazione e felicità ma era
anche come se lasciasse intendere ei
ragazzina io ce l'ho fatta
ecco in quel momento in quel preciso
momento io mi sono resa conto che nel
contesto dove ero non sarei riuscita a
vivere quello che stava vivendo in quel
momento il signor luciano quindi torno
nel mio ufficio chiamo mia mamma e le
dico guardan un ricordo dove come ma ci
deve essere un corso universitario
serale da qualche parte per favore
informati
dopo tre giorni ero iscritta a economia
e commercio serale ma ho continuato a
lavorare in impregilo per ben altri tre
anni poi sono nate in una banca d'affari
poi sono passata da accenture
perché vi ho raccontato
la mia esperienza
perché nel momento in cui ho deciso di
iscrivermi in università e non stavo
facendo un piano b io mi stavo dando
un'alternativa
un piano b e un piano secondario
d'emergenza che viene attivato nel caso
il piano principale
risulti fallimentare o non applicabile e
che attenzione viene concepito elaborato
assieme al piano ha
quindi potenzialmente il piano b ha lo
stesso problema del piano a e del piano
c ovvero l'idea che tu oggi persona o
manager d'impresa abbia una buona
capacità di prevedere gli esiti futuri
ma guardiamoci intorno
i contesti i mercati sono sempre state
complesse
solo che oggi ce ne stiamo rendendo un
pochino più conto
i problemi sono sistemici composti da
tanti elementi
elementi interdipendenti che come tali
variano molto velocemente se in contesti
così caratterizzati noi ragioniamo in
termini di piano a piano b e piano c ci
esporremmo verso le enormi conseguenze
negative di quegli eventi che saranno
comunque sempre
imprevedibili
quindi il mio suggerimento è quello di
passare dall'idea del piano b al piano
anti fragile
ante fragile un termine un po strano che
è stato coniato da nassim taleb
professore di ingegneria del rischio
all'istituto politecnico di new york
anti fragile l'anti fragilità e una
proprietà di un elemento o di una
persona
tale per cui sottoposto a
incertezza volatilità rischio stress
caos
questo elemento non solo resiste ma
addirittura cresce e migliora
giusto per darvi un'idea
questo è fragile
se arriva uno shock si rompe
questo è robusto resiste ma fino a un
certo punto
il fiore bocca di leone e resiliente il
suo stelo ha una proprietà bilaterale
simmetrica tale per cui anche se lo
schiacciate lui torna nella posizione
iniziale
e lui e chris gardner
che è un esempio di anti fragilità
probabilmente avete visto il film la
ricerca della felicità ispirata alla sua
storia ha subito ogni tipo di avversità
negativa ha vissuto in mezzo alla strada
con il figlioletto non aveva un soldo si
doveva inventare un pasto
eppure superare queste difficoltà li ha
proprio permesso di diventare un broker
è un imprenditore milionario di new york
lui dice il piano b non funziona se il
piano b fosse veramente buono allora
sarebbe il tuo piano principale
e aggiunge se io avessi avuto un piano b
mi avrebbe distratto di nuovo dal mio
piano a
molte volte noi facciamo un piano b
perché abbiamo paura di fallire
e qui torno alla mia esperienza
personale
ricordo molto bene quel giorno che ho
fallito
amorosamente il test di map per entrare
mckinsey l'avevo provato cento volte a
casa e riuscivo a passarlo a rivoli e lo
sbaglio non so se avete presente la
sensazione la sensazione del del grande
fallimento del treno che è passato però
è anche vero
che sempre in quel periodo entro in un
aula universitaria
e c'era un corso facoltativo che si
chiamava marketing io non sapevo nemmeno
cosa fosse dopo dieci minuti mi son
detta ok finalmente ti ho trovato non
era l'amministrazione non era la finanza
ma nemmeno la consulenza era questo
marketing che volevo fare
certo non avrei immaginato che dopo tre
anni sarei stata io la docente ufficiale
di quel corso e che da lì poi mi sarebbe
stata offerta l'opportunità di fare un
dottorato e sarebbe partita la mia
carriera universitaria
perché il fallimento e parte naturale di
un approccio anti fragile è funzionale
alla crescita
quante volte
quando le cose non vanno come le avete
previste vi dite adesso mi serve un
piano b sì lo diciamo ma non è un vero
piano b
in realtà vi state spingendo trovare
delle soluzioni a problemi nuovi
spesso vi state staccando da quello che
sapete è che ha funzionato in passato
proprio per riuscire a vedere questo
nuovo state allenando la vostra anti
fragilità
quindi palese che questa l'anti
fragilità sia innanzitutto un'attitudine
delle persone
quello che però io vi propongo è di
prendere
l'idea di anti fragilità e di applicarla
alla pianificazione
per dire
non ti serve un piano b ma ti serve un
unico piano che sia anti fragile
a questo punto la domanda è quali sono
le caratteristiche di un piano anti
fragile ve ne propongo tre
prima caratteristica è basato sulla
sperimentazione
ma sperimentazione continua sperimento
all'inizio per fare il piano e poi basta
quando si sperimenta si faranno
tantissimi errori ma è probabile che
saranno numerosi più piccoli e vi
porteranno un successo più grande
d'altronde il signor dyson ha sviluppato
5.127 prototipi dell'aspirapolvere che
noi oggi conosciamo
prima di arrivare al successo
seconda caratteristica del piano anti
fragile e aperto al opzionalità cioè se
tu sei un impresa devi avere molto
chiara qual è l'acqua porcus qual è la
tua vision ma sottostante devi essere
agile per questo devi avere un
portafoglio dinamico di opzioni
queste opzioni queste alternative
vengono testate sul campo e quello ti fa
vedere quali sono destinati a fallire e
quali saranno più di successo
perché è meglio fallire in parallelo che
fallire in linea
francamente anche solo se sei il ceo di
un'azienda io non sono certa che ti
verrà sempre data la possibilità di
implementare il piano b aspettare che
fallisca e poi attivare
scusate implementare il piano a
e poi successivamente il piano b fallire
in parallelo è meglio che fallire in
linea e tutto questo attenzione e molto
razionale perché dipende dalle
informazioni che ottieni non possiamo
controllare gli eventi ma possiamo
indirizzare l'anti e fragilità
terza caratteristica del piano anche
fragile
fa leva sulle relazioni
cioè pensiamoci bene le relazioni sono
per definizione
plastiche
sono dei vettori di adattamento
di agilità oggi ci sono le aziende che
spingono i prodotti e quelle che fanno
leva sull'ecosistema
relazionale queste seconde stanno
mettendo la complessità
stanno mettendo
lo stress
perché le relazioni probabilmente ve ne
siete accorti sono stress ma proprio nel
momento in cui noi andiamo a eliminare i
fattori di stress dalla nostra vita noi
diventiamo deboli
capisco anche che questa idea del piano
anti fragile sia più facile da pensare
sulla piccola impresa o sull'impresa
start up piuttosto che sulla grande
azienda perché le grandi aziende sono
per definizioni più vulnerabili come i
grandi animali
però vi voglio portare l'esempio
positivo
azienda leader nel mercato dei
pneumatici
a un certo punto scoppia la pandemia le
salta la catena di fornitura questa
azienda inizia a produrre con le
stampanti 3d che precedentemente
utilizzava solo in fase di
prototipazione
dopo poco anche il fornitore inizia
utilizzare le stampante in 3d per
produrre lotti più piccoli che cosa ne
consegue
ne consegue che tutta la filiera
migliore
meno costi
eliminato completamente il magazzino e
più velocità non avevano un piano b ma
hanno mostrato anti fragilità
quindi in conclusione il mio messaggio è
di
abbracciare l'incertezza che comunque è
insita nello scorrere del tempo
nel momento in cui pensiamo di
controllare incertezza e volatilità con
un piano b
incorriamo solo in un'illusione in un
falso senso di rassicurazione che a quel
punto veramente ti esporrà verso le
conseguenze negative degli eventi non ti
serve un piano b ti serve un unico piano
che sia anti fragile
io non ho mai ragionato in termini di
piano b e vi posso dire che quella
sensazione che viveva quel giorno il
signor luciano io oggi la conosco e non
è finita qua sto ancora sperimentando e
sono sempre nello stesso piano
e voi
grazie
[Applauso]